قال مراسل الجزيره ان سفنا وناقلات متوقفه
قباله السواحل الجيبوتيه كتبت في لوحه
التعريف الاليه الخاصه بها للمره الاولى
عباره تفيد بعدم علاقتها باسرائيل لتجنب
استهدافها من قبل انصار الله الحوثيين
اثناء عبورها من البحر الاحمر واظهر موقع
تتبع حركه الملاحه الدوليه قيام سفينه
حاويات تحمل علم سنغفوره واخرى ناقله نفط
تحمل علم
بكتابه هذه العباره قبل ابحار هما من
المياح من المياه الاقليميه الجيبوتيه ثم
مديق باب
المندب الى شبكه مراسلينا معنا من امام
ميناء جيبوتي مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق ومن
واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسيني مرحبا
بكما وسنبدا معك ناصر الحسيني ماذا في
المعلومات بشان ضبط شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه
وايضا ردود الفعل ان كانت سجلت بشان تكرار
هجمات جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين هذه
المره على سفن امريكيه وبريطانيه في البحر
الاحمر نعم هناك شعور الان بالفل بان
الولايات المتحده اصبحت ليست لوحدها وانما
على المجتمع الدولي الذي يدعم الولايات
المتحده في قوه سانت كوم مثلا او مع
الحلفاء الاوروبيين انهم بالفعل الان امام
مشكله حقيقيه ذلك ان انصار الله الحوثيين
اصبحوا يشكلون الان قوه عسكريه حقيقيه
تتطلب ايضا من الجانب الامريكي وشركائه
الغربيين التدخل بقوات عسكريه ولدينا هذا
النموذج لهذه المعلومات الجديده التي
اخرجها الامريكيون الى العلن لاول مره في
الساعات القليله الماضيه القياده الوسطى
تعطينا تفاصيل ما حدث قرب سواحل صومال نحن
نتحدث الان بعيدا عن باب المندب او عن حتى
البحر الاحمر جنوبا قرب سواحل الصومال
كانت هناك عمليه عسكريه جد معقده وجد
خطيره فقد الامريكيون خلالها اثنين من
رجال البحريه الامريكي ما زال يتم البحث
عنهما في في تلك المنطقه وخلاصه القول ان
الولايات المتحده وقوات سانكوم او القياده
الوسطى ومن معها من دول تمكنت من نرصد
احدى السفن وتم الهجوم على تلك السفينه من
طرف قوات البحريه الامريكيه وقوات القياده
الوسطى كانت هناك عمليه انزال جد معقده
بالمروحيات على ظهر السفينه وهناك ا تشف
الامريكيون الى اي حد كما يقول تقول
الولايات المتحده والقياده الوسطى الى اي
حد ايران متورطه بالفعل في هذه العمليات
الداعمه عسكريا للجانب الحوثي لانصار الله
اكتشف الامريكيون اسلحه كما يقولون جد
متطوره رؤوس حربيه اجهزه اطلاق اجهزه
توجيه ايه صواريخ متوسطه المدى وقصيره
المدى وكل التكنولوجيا المرتبطه بها اضافه
الى الرؤوس الحربيه وفوجئ الى حد ما
الامريكيون عندما نقرا برصان ذلك البيان
للقياده الوسطى فوجئوا بحجم ليس الاسلحه
وانما حجم التطور التكنولوجي لهذه الاسلحه
وهي ما تمكن الان كما يقول بيان القياده
الوسطى انصار له الحوثييين من الاستمرار
في هذه المعارك البحريه واستهداف السفن
بكل حريه اليوم قبل قليل تم استهداف باخره
سفينه تجاريه على ما يبدو تحمل على مالطا
امس تم استهداف وبشكل مباشر مع اصابه
مباشره لسفينه تجاريه امريكيا الاي
جيبرالتار ايجل والله وحده هي كما يتوقع
كثير المتحدثين الى اي حد سيتمكن انصار
الله الحوثيين من الزياده في حجم هذه
الهجمات هذه الهجمات حقيقه اصبحت الان
تشكل مشكله عوصه حقيقيه لا يتحدث
الامريكيين عن علاقتها بحرب على غزه لكن
يتحدثون عن المشكل عن مشكل انصار الله
بشكل منعزل ويتم ربطه بايران بدل ان يربط
بالعدوان الاسرائيلي مستمر على غزه